今日は外せそうとタッチと4編成ですってけど皆さん実は最近始め見えず別途パークに
取りもどきたの覚えてますでしょうか
乗り物にもムーン
まあ車買ったんじゃないかな車買ったぜないから来るなよねじゃあみんなで使う車買っ
たんですけども何かにタブー
まだ綺麗なんんめっちゃ機でメッツ機で車はい今日は何だろう綺麗な車を大
めちゃめちゃに落書きされる動き出していこうと思います
です
何ですねこればかりは多分失礼だろカバーしきれないんでもう2人の仕掛人になって
もらって悪が記されの前提に多く方を発見するのでめっちゃくちゃかけたこれも誰には
もうする知ってる前提でわざと怒ってモスあの子でドッキリ仕掛けがあるすわーって
感じでそんだけですか敗2分けで仕込みをガッツリでございます
いやー車きれいだからねえんらくないんですけどこういうスペ例がありまして
スプラトゥーンみたいな超ヤンキー使うじゃこれ
おごりっ繰り出すベレーなんですけどもこれすごいところがですね布で拭き取ると
取れるようになっておりますだからものが一般的なイメージとしてなくコスプレかけ
られたら落ちない感がすごいですね
それを買ったばっかりの車にバンバンやられるとする
可能カーゲットも車の変わり果てた姿を見ておこういう悲しいまずはと畜
何かしらのアクションが来て起きると思うんですよ大切なものが汚された瞬間の人の顔
見てみたいと思いますめっちゃ準備したんで早速やっていきましょーいまいか
me
4日地獄言ってるかな
持っていたです
よくわからん
big 車やばいった上田作りの中キュラ挑んでおります
うわっ待ってっ
本当に大丈夫これちょっと言えないが起きるこれ
山隈狙って競って待って大丈夫かな
マイカーいい
b 4
立通知きてたから腐ったのこれか
所が来たよねっあっはぁ
エイ
始め技術な poso 月た n スタず六ポスタース
どうでしょうはじめ消えろ
[音楽]
ブーンっ
こんなもんだったらどうでしょ
dee
[音楽]
んん
ああああああ
はいというわけで完成しましたいかがでしょうか
もう年間こういうの見たことあるんですけど本当に馬鹿な人が書いたようなスプレーの
悪戯ポップしたんでありとリアリティが出てるのではないかなと思いますでここから
ターゲットを誘って車に乗せるねー
リアクション王をお楽しみください家ごはん車ぼかすでみたいと思います
なかったん
大家さん
これはまあ車を動かす体とながら
オデッセイ
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
持っています
[音楽]
これだけでございません
低迷
いつか僕はせんかっ
[音楽]
dea
car
ana あああっ